i mean you have the famous quote from
spaceballs
evil will always triumph because good is
dumb
[Laughter]
why is evil important in storytelling
i think evil is important in
storytelling because
it's a real thing
i think a lot of people try to hide that
there isn't evil in the world
and i think that's a disservice
because you want to explain
both sides
of every story to try to give
to try to give the best thought process
for it you can
especially as a father now now that we
have a son he's 11 and we're
homeschooling him and so you kind of get
to pick and choose how you explain
things to him how you decide like
critical race theory is a big argument
right now
and we definitely try to explain both
sides of every story it's like this is
this is what really or this is what
really happened this is the truth we're
not going to candy code it we're not
going to
make up some
fairy tale
and evil is real and so you want
people to know that you know such people
that you're educating and so i feel like
in movies
it's important too because you want to
root for someone you a lot of people
like happy endings i mean i like happy
endings personally
uh my wife likes tragedies but um
that's her
but you kind of want to have this this
battle of good and evil has been
the tale as old as time
you know back to the very beginning of
existence
it's always good versus evil i mean the
bible is all good versus evil and so
i mean you have the famous quote from
spaceballs
evil will always triumph because good is
dumb
which i always think about
uh
obviously not the case but
everybody wants to be on the winning
team there's a thing that's really
popular i think it's called sports i'm
not involved so i'm not aware of it but
people love being on a winning team
whether you're on you follow a football
team or you
go to a church that you like or you have
a club that you're into you always want
to be on that on something positive
right with like-minded people and sports
is a huge huge element of that
there's always a winner and a loser
and
in life everyone kind of loses because
we all
you know come and live and die right
there's there's an end an end game for
everyone essentially death and taxes
death and taxes exactly
oh my gosh that's the running joke in
our house for adulthood uh we keep
telling our son it's like oh you're 11.
you're going to be doing taxes soon it's
like oh no that's the thing he's the
most terrified of his taxes we keep
telling him he should be
but i think evil is important because
without
evil then there's no
nothing to overcome you know there's no
good guy saving the day there's no hero
if there's nothing to beat it's just a
person sitting around looking for
something to do i guess
but i mean that's been in existence of
storytelling forever i would be
wondering if there's a
if you did a movie with no
antagonist
and it would just be a person existing
that wouldn't be a very exciting movie
because nothing would really happen
it doesn't necessarily have to be evil
but there's usually always an antagonist
of some kind it might be taxes it could
be the irs
but if it wasn't then it would just be a
person sitting around i always love when
people tell you like oh you got to do a
reality show on me like my life is so
exciting so excited so crazy like you
wouldn't believe it how crazy my life is
and it'd be like okay like so if i shut
up your house tomorrow for two hours for
the camera what would happen they'd be
like well
i mean i'd be cleaning the bathroom
and i gotta drop my kids off at school
uh i'm like yeah it's not very exciting
there's no story there like you would
have to create a story and the only way
to create a story is to create some kind
of genre or a drama create some kind of
drama with some kind of inciting
incident with some kind of conflict and
with a conflict there's something to
overcome
it doesn't have to be evil necessarily
but evil takes a different term too i
mean i think taxes are evil to an extent
though i appreciate everything they
bring us well sure yeah they're now this
is necessary necessary because they pay
for different services that we rely on
yep but there's definitely a lot of evil
in our world and in our country and in
our neighborhoods and i mean you can
watch the nightly news and see
how horrific things are
and so
that is something that also unifies us
people are scared of evil things
and when you can overcome that or have a
hero that overcomes the evil and saves
the day and gives you that happy ending
i mean a lot of people
ideally want a happy ending everyone
wants to live happily ever after
so
i like giving people something that they
they can enjoy like that you wanna you
wanna have that happy ending i think
sure so a movie about somebody
meditating on a bench
where nothing bad happens to them
is is incredibly boring but if we
peppered in
various things you know maybe
someone asking them to move over because
they need to sit down on their lunch
hour to use their cell phone to call
their bookie and they're screaming
because they just lost a bunch of money
in on a game
yep and this person's trying to become
spiritual and detached
well in a movie a movie without an
antagonist is an instructional
you know you can watch a workout video
and a workout video the villain is fat i
guess you know and that could be your
story
well i'm gonna watch this workout video
for half an hour and i'm gonna kill that
fat i'm gonna burn that fat so bad
and even then but i mean you can watch a
yoga instructional video
and it's a person a person doing yoga
for half an hour there's no villain
there's nothing you're trying to
overcome
your
ability to feel good or some some stress
you have on your person or everything
and that's an example but i think if you
told someone hey we're gonna sit down
and watch a half an hour yoga video
tonight after work what do you think
they're gonna be like what are you
talking about that's weird weirdo like
why would i watch that after go home
have some dinner have grab a beer and
watch a half an hour yoga video that's
strange
so i think i think that that's
that's why that that type of stuff
doesn't isn't is included
who are your favorite villains
and why i really like complex villains
that
a lot of times you have villains that
are selfish
or they're they just want something they
want more money they want more land they
want to stomp on whoever they possibly
can to get what they want
those villains usually aren't nearly as
compelling
i like villains that have
more ideals or want something for a very
specific reason and a lot of times their
reasons are good and makes sense to us
that's really good writing like you want
someone to be able to humanize your
villain
to an extent
because then it's like then your hero
gets a little bit more complicated
i'm trying to think of a specific
example now
that's a good one
i mean of course i like villains that
are
charismatic like a freddy krueger i
think is a fun villain in our house
we're a house divided my wife's into
jason and i'm into freddy
and so
i always like the fact that that villain
is a
is a caricature essentially of a
nightmare
but
i'm not a i'm not a fan of big
government
uh i don't
like that like that's definitely a big
villain for me across the board growing
up in a political family like my father
was a lawyer and a judge and i've had
more politics than i would ever care to
deal with ever
run through my life so
i'm not a fan of that at all
and to me you know movies are escapism
i don't like dramas i don't like art
house films i can't get into stuff that
wins the academy award most the time
because i'm just like i don't want to
relive someone else's pain like that at
least
in a realistic way
in a slasher movie if somebody gets
their head chopped off with a battle axe
i mean it's a little bit different
that's a little more
cartoonish
but you know someone losing their
house to a mortgage and a divorce and
having their whole life get up ended and
they're miserable and i'm like i don't
want to watch that like i don't want to
experience that
i want escapism i want something that's
colorful and crazy and so i don't have
to worry about the real evils of the
world
that exist i don't want to worry about
my
kid getting snatched or you know someone
robbing our house and oh my gosh we just
had to get a mailbox because people kept
stealing packages off our porch it's
just like
and then you got one of the ring cameras
but the ring camera doesn't see in the
dark
so he didn't pick up the people that
come in the dark and it's the whole
thing
but and now you're in a database and now
i'm gonna database yeah
exactly because you walked in front of
your own camera
it's ridiculous
i mean i think
i think the the real villains are are in
reality much more than they are in
movies and um
i like villains that are more cartoonish
because the idea of a true evil and a
real evil in reality is not
one that i enjoy
so i think that i like more of the
cartoonish villains and the the big over
the dr evils of the world you know i
appreciate more so than uh
then what could be like a real actual
villain
you